[Música]
en irak unos activistas presentaron una
campaña con afiches haciendo un llamado
para boicotear las elecciones
legislativas que serán llevadas a cabo
el 10 de octubre hace 2 años cientos de
miles de jóvenes salieron a las calles
para exigir el fin de la corrupción y de
la tutela de irán sobre este país pero
los manifestantes fueron brutalmente
reprimidos más de 600 personas fueron
asesinadas y 17.000 más resultaron
heridas esos crímenes quedaron impunes
pero muchos ven en ellos la mano de
grupos armados chiítas proiraníes
procedentes de asia al shaab y una
organización paramilitar creada en el
año 2014 unos jóvenes activistas
presentaron entonces esta campaña de
boicot a las legislativas para protestar
contra la impunidad
summer alsaidi es el portavoz de esta
campaña actualmente vive en el exilio en
turquía
realizamos varias acciones para fichas
de la campaña no votaré encima de los
afiches de todos los candidatos sin
importar cuál fuera también le pegamos
con zapatos a los afiches de los
candidatos
miren son los socios de las fuerzas de
movilización popular es una manera de
decir como ustedes no me respetan yo no
los respeto
participe en las manifestaciones del
primero de octubre de 2019 hasta cuando
me fui de irak en julio de 2020
y como perseguían y apuñalan jóvenes en
los lugares estaciones
a veces hombres armados a bordo de un
vehículo mitsubishi de color blanco se
detenían en frente de los manifestantes
y les disparaban metíamos a los heridos
en unos tux que los llevaban al hospital
unos francotiradores también disparaban
a los manifestantes
estaban en los techos de los edificios
disparaban a jóvenes que sólo un día van
la bandera iraquí
desde hace dos años el país también ha
sido sacudido por una ola de asesinatos
de militantes de la sociedad civil más
de 70 activistas y periodistas han
muerto entre los cuales está y jeff al
wasl y un periodista anticorrupción
asesinado en el frente de su casa el
pasado 9 de mayo no se llevó a cabo
ningún juicio ninguna investigación
sobre estos crímenes la oficina de
investigaciones de información y la del
procurador están todas controladas por
los partidos religiosos en el poder para
que estas elecciones sean verosímiles
hay que juzgar a los asesinos de los
manifestantes y prohibir a los partidos
que poseen armas que se presenten a
estas elecciones
yo he culto y donde primero
que viene con la
plantilla que también diría yo
por eso de que
el hombre que aparece en estas imágenes
con una pistola en la mano está
disfrazado de joker el famoso adversario
de batman se llama be in you y es la
cara de un grupo anti feminista coreano
los adeptos de este movimiento afirman
defender el derecho de los hombres
coreanos que estarían amenazados por las
feministas a quienes ellos acosan
violentamente por internet o incluso
directamente en las calles las
militantes feministas del grupo high que
significa tsunami en coreano son
consideradas radicales por sus
opositores y durante una manifestación
en agosto pasado tuvieron mucho miedo
siempre nos seguía gritando hay una
mosca aquí y nos roció con una pistola
de agua
y
las militantes tenían miedo de la
pistola de agua porque hubo amenazas de
terrorismo del esperma en la sociedad
coreana
por ejemplo con esperma pulverizado
lanzado sobre la cabeza de las mujeres
en los buses
y tú más que eso
no sabíamos que el líquido había en esa
pistola y aunque hubiéramos
siempre nos seguía y gritaba muy cerca
de nosotras en ese momento estábamos
realmente el problema se estábamos
aterrorizados
contactamos a be in you él afirma no
haber cometido ninguna violencia contra
las militantes de este movimiento y dice
querer denunciar su radicalidad y su
apariencia este hombre tiene la
costumbre de hacer provocaciones como
por ejemplo llegar disfrazado de mujer a
las manifestaciones feministas
[Música]
en javanés se disfrazaban de mujeres y
se ponían pelucas de pelo largo para
ridiculizar nos tiene que ver con que
las mujeres de nuestro grupo adhieren al
movimiento liberarse del corsé que
combate los estereotipos sobre la manera
de vestir de las mujeres
pelo corto sin maquillaje así como las
feministas coreanas se alejan
completamente de los estándares
femeninos durante el verano la triple
campeona olímpica de tiro con arco and
sand recibió toda una ola de insultos
por internet a causa de su sencillo
corte de pelo algunos anti feministas
incluso exigieron que devolviera sus
medallas una polémica que reveló una
sociedad todavía muy conservadora a
pesar del fervor del movimiento mutuo
entre los jóvenes coreanos y los
significativos avances de los últimos
años
como el sexismo está tan extendido por
korea el anti feminismo es totalmente
natural y pienso que ha ganado mucho
poder en particular ligado a una cultura
en línea muy asentada en internet es
posible ser despedida por ser feminista
en korea el término feminista solo es un
término peyorativo que se ha convertido
en una palabrota
es todo por hoy en los observadores de
france 24 si quiere entrar en contacto
con la producción del programa a todos
nuestros puntos de contacto aparecen en
sus pantallas esperamos sus vídeos y sus
historias hasta pronto